qu'est-ce que tu détestes le plus dans
le ménage quelle est la tâche qui te
de voir
une faire le ménage dans la chambre de
mes frères
je m'appelle Aziza je suis 12 ans à la
maison je dois faire tout le ménage et
mes frères ne veulent jamais m'aider
c'est pas juste
le mercredi le matin je dois faire la
vaisselle quand on peut mettre un
travail du matin
l'après-midi vers 2h je vais jouer au
volley et le soir je dois faire la
vaisselle je dois m'occuper que la
maison soit en ordre
la semaine
le lundi mardi quand je serai comme chez
école je dois m'occuper de la maison
soit en ordre aussi
j'aurais évité qu'il avait celle dans
l'évier
et le samedi dimanche bon ben je vais
faire comme le mercredi
par contre ça se fait que ce soit toi
qui t'occupes de tout ça
il trouve toujours une excuse il
travaille ils savent le faire mais ils
veulent pas le faire
vous allez qu'à faire vos vaisselle
vous-même si chacun lave son assiette
c'est plus vite ils disent mais ça sert
à rien elle sera mal fait comme ça donc
c'est moi qui dois faire le sel ensuite
autrement quand
je sais pas moyen de la vaisselle dans
l'évier 10h Lisa fait la vaisselle donc
je suis obligée de la faire
la vaisselle
d'une fille de faire ça que c'est pas le
travail à
son il peut sortir il peut aller au
cinéma quand il veut il peut aller chez
les copains et tout donc la fille elle
fait le ménage elle fait la vaisselle
elle fait des tâches ménagères
et alors moi j'aimerais bien être un
garçon pour ne pas avoir à faire les
tâches
est-ce que tes frères ont pas tendance
un petit peu à te donner des ordres et à
jouer un peu le rôle paternel
ainsi quand même il donne des ordres et
comment ça se passe qu'est-ce qui donne
comme morde comment tu réagis toi
la chienne range le fauteuil range la
maison range le salon
qu'est-ce que tu détestes le plus dans
le ménage quelle est la tâche qui te
[Musique]
de voir
une faire le ménage dans la chambre de
mes frères
parce que c'est pas moi l'hiver alors là
je suis vraiment pas d'accord parce que
non seulement je vais faire mais en plus
je dois faire leur ménage
ce qu'il salisse
de faire la vaisselle de t'aider de
jamais
et tu penses que ça peut changer avec le
temps
pour les convaincre qu'est-ce que tu
pourrais leur dire
j'arrête de faire la vaisselle
un jour Aziza va se mettre en grève de
vaisselle vous verrez bon Aziza c'est
pas synonyme de Cendrillon faut
peut-être pas non plus exagérer mais
mais quoique sujet est important
puisqu'elle a décidé d'en discuter
pendant pratiquement une demi-heure avec
nous aujourd'hui mais ce ne sera pas un
dialogue entre toi et moi il y a
d'autres d'autres personnes que je vais
te présenter tout de suite à commencer
par Stéphanie Stéphanie tu as 14 ans 14
ans et demi c'est ça et tu trouves un
petit peu dans le même cas tu te corvais
sans arrêt quoi en gros enfin tu nous
raconteras tout à l'heure un petit peu
plus loin ta maman Aziza madame Sophie
boubezari bonjour madame enchanté de
faire votre connaissance à ma droite la
personne qui va peut-être te défendre
Aziza est plutôt aussi Stéphanie c'est
Madame Françoise Antonini vous êtes chef
de cabinet de Madame André secrétaire
d'État chargé des droits de la femme
bonjour madame
dans le fauteuil de l'accusé ici à ma
gauche Elias je crois que de toute façon
tes deux frères pourraient être aussi à
la même place que toi mais c'est toi qui
va trinquer aujourd'hui tu as 19 ans et
demi et demi et tu es étudiant en
géographie c'est ça très bien et enfin
pour conclure ce tour de table il faut
que je te présente Isabelle Morini Bosc
bonjour Isabelle bonjour vous êtes
journaliste avsd et vous intéressez
aujourd'hui au cas d'Aziza bien je crois
que les cartes sont sur la table alors
maintenant c'est règlement de compte à
Hauteville City va commencer donc en
fait je voudrais savoir une chose à Lisa
est-ce que tu es ici dans le but de
régler des comptes ou quelle est ta
motivation pourquoi est-ce que tu as eu
envie de participer à ces pas juste en
fait
pour dire que c'était pas juste
mais dans l'espoir quand même de voir
quelque chose c'est pas simplement pour
dire c'est pas juste ça va pas j'en ai
marre
Isabelle j'ai envie de savoir comment il
y a sa réagit quand il a pris que sa
sœur voulait venir sur le plateau de
l'émission parce que tout à l'heure
quand vous présentiez Vincent vous vous
ditiez manifestement as-tu
le reportage qui m'a assez surpris je le
voyais pas si fort déjà
comme vu comme le reportage a été
représenté vraiment on a vraiment
l'impression qu'elle fait vraiment tout
centré aussi
c'est pour ça que j'ai des tickets comme
tu n'as pas l'impression qu'elle fait
tout non alors est-ce que tu penses à
Zac le reportage a exagéré penses-tu que
ça a été suffisamment objectif ou pas
c'est représenter un peu en général
c'est quand même très représentatif
ouais mais pas trop quand même je
voudrais que Stéphanie tu me racontes ce
qui se passe pour toi par rapport au cas
d'Aziza c'est la même chose ou quels
sont les différences oui mais
disons que c'est plutôt que ma mère elle
travaille pas c'est ma mère ou moi mais
jamais mon frère qui est à la maison et
qui travaille pas non plus ah oui et
c'est tout le temps moi qui doit aller
acheter quelque chose ou faire le ménage
il est très heureux que ça se passe
comme ça le dimanche il est à la télé
alors que c'est ma mère et moi qui dois
me faire toi la maison et qu'en pense sa
maman elle est elle aussi contre ça ou
elle lui dit rien elle laisse faire et
toi tu es trop belle
qu'est-ce que tu lui dis que il ferait
mieux de differ lui aussi mais elle me
dit que non c'est le rôle d'une fille à
elle aussi dit que c'est le rôle d'une
fille c'est vrai vous avez dit ça madame
votre fille vous pensez que le rôle
d'une fille c'est d'être une j'allais
dire une femme de ménage je pense qu'il
y a le droit de pour quelque chose il y
a quelque chose aussi à faire que la
fille soit à faire quelque chose
ménagères tant qu'elle est petite elle a
des choses à faire
des petites des petits rôles à faire
mais est-ce que vous imaginez par
exemple rentrer à la maison un soir et
voir Elias par exemple en train de
passer l'aspirateur c'est mon rêve
ça c'est mon rêve je comprends bien que
ma mère travaille et que elle rentre
elle est fatiguée elle a pas le temps de
des fois on a pas le temps préparer à
manger elle rentre tard le soir alors
faut bien qu'on se débrouille par le
propre moyen et des fois c'est nous qui
nous débrouillons on fait à manger pour
pour Aziza aussi pour vous tous pour
nous tous dont elle tu veux dire c'est
le ménage aussi on le fait aussi de
temps en temps c'est pas faut pas dire
que c'est c'est tous les jours mais de
temps en temps on le fait c'est une fois
par trimestre une fois par an une fois
c'est plus c'est plus que ça quand même
je pensais que les deux problèmes
étaient pas assimilables que quand vous
disiez que c'était normal qu'une fille
le fasse c'était en quelque sorte
inscrit dans vos tables de la loi et que
la répartition des rôles c'était les
garçons
tout pour eux entre guillemets et la
fille vraiment travaille en fait si les
garçons mettent la main à la pâte vous
seriez pas compte bien sûr c'est quand
ils mettent la main
des rôles d'une fille c'est de faire le
ménage et de s'occuper de la maison mais
c'est pas le seul rôle et c'est
peut-être pas le plus important
oui je voudrais réagir au début de cette
émission parce que c'est effectivement
bon je représente le secrétariat d'État
doit charger des droits des femmes mais
donc aussi des droits et des petites
filles des adolescentes et des jeunes
filles et je remarque dans cette
discussion qui en fait on retrouve les
mêmes problèmes que pour la femme adulte
c'est à dire que la femme adulte doit
concilier et sa vie familiale et sa vie
professionnelle
et au revoir le même le même tableau
quand les femmes étaient des enfants et
c'est tout à fait normal que on retrouve
ça dans la vie après dire que si les
mamans continuent à élever leurs enfants
comme la maman de Stéphanie qui dit
après tout nous deux on s'occupe de la
maison parce que toi tu es une fille et
puis bah le frère il reste dans son
fauteuil si effectivement ce garçon est
élevé comme ça je crains fort que plus
tard le problème revienne exactement au
même c'est à dire que s'il épouse une
jeune femme il trouvera normal que la
jeune femme même si elle travaille face
et son travail familial et son travail
professionnel et ça je dirais que pour
Aziza je pense que c'est très difficile
de trouver une solution au moins dans
l'immédiat le seul chose un problème de
société je dirais que on ne fait avancer
les choses que comme avec des émissions
comme celle-ci ou c'est comme ça qu'on
fait avancer en disant bon bah il y a un
problème puisqu'il y a des tas de gens
qui ignorent totalement ce problème mais
c'est un réel problème même si je pense
que la mixité à l'école a un petit peu
fait évoluer et fait que bon vous vous
représentez chacun chacune vous avez un
problème de ce genre mais il y a des
familles ou quand même il y a une
répartition sans doute plus équilibrée
entre les garçons et les filles et en
grande partie dues à la mixité à l'école
donc les choses évoluent mais c'est vrai
que c'est lent et je comprends quand on
est patience parce que c'est pas drôle
de faire essayer de voir le soir on
retrouve les mêmes choses que les mêmes
choses que dans la vie professionnelle
en fait parce que Aziza est obligé de
faire ses devoirs le soir et il est
logique qu'elle aide à la maison c'est
dire que c'est normal sa maman dit bien
que ce serait bien que les frères aides
mais c'est normal quasi ça fasse nous
avons aussi interrogé Aziza d'autres
personnes sur ton problème qui vont elle
aussi nous dire si leur semble normal ou
pas que ce soit toi qui colle tout voilà
bon bah des fois je suis machin mais
sinon
je fais pas la vaisselle ou
bon ou autre chose je m'occupe de ma
chambre ça va pas toujours et sinon
autre chose et tu trouves que c'est
normal
ben
je pense que
l'homme a ses responsabilité et puis la
femme les sienne
tout le monde dans une famille doit
s'occuper des tâches ménagères ce qui
fait plus le ménage se sentait sœur ou
toi ce sont plutôt mes sœurs et pourquoi
je n'aime pas bien ça et elle elles
aiment ça
non pas spécialement mais
c'est comme ça voilà c'est tu penses pas
que ça pourrait changer si sur moi
et tu serais prêt toi à changer les
choses alors proposer de faire le ménage
à leur place pas tellement pourquoi je
n'aime pas trop ça
est-ce que ton frère fait des tâches
ménagères
quand il rentre il fait la vaisselle il
passe l'aspirateur ça dépend des jours
si la selon son travail je peux vous
dire qu'il a été très difficile
d'arriver à trouver une jeune fille
comme la dernière qui parlait parce que
c'est très effectivement difficile
d'arriver à trouver un homme qui qui
s'adonne à Jean de tache on sait pas
arriver en dégoter une mais tout à fait
honnêtement il y a c'est quand même
assez agréable d'avoir en même temps une
sœur et j'allais dire une femme de
ménage dans la même personne non oui
c'est vrai
on est là tranquille tout est fait non
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est génial non
mais c'est à dire que moi je suis
rarement chez moi Hauteville je suis en
fac comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
et je rentre en fin de semaine et je
repars le dimanche pour les jours au
foot donc je suis rarement à la maison
disant alors donc tu parlais de l'excuse
du travail tout à l'heure tu disais tout
le monde travaille effectivement
on fait pas faire ça à telle personne
parce qu'il est fatigué parce qu'il a
travaillé
tu as pas envie de dire que toi des fois
tu bosses aussi plutôt parce que c'est
vrai moi je vais à l'école c'est un peu
près pareil ça m'occupe la plus grande
partie de la journée et as-tu quand même
essayer d'en parler à tes frères tu dis
dans le reportage jamais réussi à les
convaincre mais est-ce que vraiment tu
l'auras exprimé aussi fortement
qu'aujourd'hui visiblement pas parce
qu'il y a cette surprise à quel point tu
en avais marre que ce soit comme ça ben
moi je le retransmis mes messages je
sais pas si ils l'ont compris analyser
l'occasion et quand et comment tu
l'auras transmis le message bah
plusieurs fois quand il y a beaucoup vu
celle dans le livre quand il gaspille
de la vaisselle moi je leur dis je leur
dise vous pourriez utiliser un peu moins
de sel et puis vous pourriez la faire
généralement qu'est-ce qu'on te répond
dans ces cas-là
c'est pas grave laisse la fraîche la
ferai tout à l'heure et finalement ils
font pas donc finalement obligé de le
faire parce que avant que ta maman
rentre et tout ça je sais pas puisque
il a fait
en plus c'est elle qui se fait gronder
parce que vous avez fait
c'est pas là tu vas ton frère en face de
toi il est obligé de t'écouter tu as un
message peut-être plus direct à lui
transmettre
[Musique]